Hey guys, Pete here. today my Game of
Thrones Season 8 video will be the
episode 3 official trailer breakdown
this has to be one of the darkest
trailers they've ever released so we'll
brighten it up and we'll look at what
goes on and see what we think before we
jump in I want to tell you about the
game of Thrones Amino app that has
sponsored today's video if you're
unfamiliar with Amino it's an app that's
filled with global communities focused
around fandoms passions and interest the
game of thrones Amino is the community i
use the most and i love how there is
always a diverse collection of new posts
in the feed i also enjoy the fan made
quizzes about the show's characters
history and lore you could take a quiz
and compare your scores with other
members on the quizzes leaderboard
lately I've been having a lot of fun
with the new stories feature where users
can put together clips music and photos
to broadcast a story about it Game of
Thrones
topic I make a couple of these stories
with unique content each week and I
think you should download the app so you
can check them out you can interact in
my stories and make your own but you
have to download the app to get started
to check out my stories on Game of
Thrones Amino just click the link in the
description or the pin comment on this
video and follow the prompts to download
Amino for free on iOS or Android or you
can download a me know by searching your
App Store then searching for Game of
Thrones once you're in remember you can
find me there by searching my username
Pete peppers
my favorite thing we can do now book the
trace in the face
the night king is coming
the dead are already here okay so we
start out with some long shots of the
unsullied in formation and then we see
Trebuchet and we see the Dothraki on
horseback nothing stands out here as
being too surprising we just see that
they're ready for the battle the
recycled shot of Greyworm donning his
helmet comes next we've seen this a
couple times by now so there's really
nothing new to say about it
the next shot however is brand new we
see Jonathan Ayers from behind there on
a hill overlooking Winterfell and it
doesn't look like there's fighting going
on below them yet we can imagine that
dragons are involved with this but we
don't see them we have a voiceover from
Sansa who says the most heroic thing we
can do now is look truth in the face as
it cuts away we have a shot of Sanwa
looking ready to fight he's surrounded
by soldiers that you can't really make
out think he's inside the walls because
there's a torch in the shop behind the
soldiers and even though he looks as
vicious as Sam can look here I think it
makes more sense for him to stay inside
the walls based on the fact that he
isn't the warrior type after that we get
one of the clear shots of the trailer
and see Sansa and Arya on the walls
they're looking out with concern and
this goes along with the voiceover
nicely as with most of these shots of
the characters we see it looks like the
moments right before the battle begins
then we see a couple of clips that are
recycled from the first season a trailer
Davos walking along the walls looking
deep in thought and the shot of the
crypts where we see Varys and the women
and children gathered for protection the
next image is tearing in the crypts
which I don't remember seeing before
since Daenerys gave him a direct order
to stay in the crypts I assumed this
would happen but he was obviously still
outside at the end of episode 2 so stay
safe Tyrion there's another recycled
shot of Jorah outside the walls and we
get a voiceover from jon saying the
night king is coming directly after that
we see the first image of Jon engaged in
the battle itself we have a few of these
here and we've seen a few in previous
trailers in this shot there isn't
anything you can see in the background
except for that smoke or mist that we
have seen in a lot of these shots what
stands out to me in this one
is that Jon's breath is noticeable as
he exhales I tend to think that this
image is related to where we saw John
slashing in the second season eight
teaser but there's nothing to tell us
for sure and this shot either way it
seems like they want us to notice Jon's
breath here after that we get a wider
view of the front of Winterfell we see
the formation from the front this time
this lines up with the map we saw in
episode two during the war council we
see that the Dothraki are out front with
the unsullied behind them we know that
the trench they will catch on fire is
behind that like it would be behind
where the unsullied are we see some
northern soldiers on the right side of
the screen but can't see what I imagine
would be the mounted Knights at the Vale
in front of them there is a shortened
look at Arya running through the castle
which is part of what we saw in the
opening sequence in the first season a
trailer this is real short this time and
in this section she's just turned the
corner so we can't see anything behind
her at all there's a quick look at the
unsullied outside the gate you can see
what I was talking about before like
this cold mist that the White Walkers
brings with them at least that's how I'm
interpreting it next we see Beric in
the Hound who are inside where they are
isn't clear but we see that Beric's
swords ablaze and the Hound has his new
oversized dragonglass
axe in other trailers we've seen these
two inside with a lot of fire nearby in
those shots they look like they've been
fighting for some time here they look
pretty fresh like you don't see them
look like they're beat up yet so if I
had to guess I would say that they're
probably taking a role of protecting the
crypts just because we know that's the
location indoors though I mean I can't
make out anything from the layout that
we see here next we see a dragon which
because this is a dark I first thought
of course this is the night King and
Viserion
the night Kings here confirmed this is
gonna get crazy but after looking at it
and messing with the brightness I would
say that it's actually not I tend to
think it's Daenerys on drogon because of
the coloring of the dragon itself but
you really can't tell I'm not an expert
in brightening these things up and I
haven't really seen an image
line that does it really well either so
I'm kind of convinced that this was put
in the trailer for that reason like you
really can't tell who's on the back like
the rider does not show up no matter
what I do there's points where I think
maybe I see Daenerys' white hair but
it also looks like there's definitely a
black cloak on the person who's flying
it so who knows
either way the dragon's wings look like
they're intact rather than what we've
seen with Viserion he has the holes in
his wings so you guys can tell me in the
comments what you think we see here
there's a quick transition sequence
where we see more unsullied and then we
get one of the truly interesting shots
of the trailer we see Theon Greyjoy's
shooting flaming arrows in the godswood
totally unrelated to this trailer and
what's going on here but it kicked in my
memory of him bringing Sansa there for
her wedding with Ramsay here though he's
definitely doing what he said he was
gonna do in the last episode you can see
the weirwood branches behind him I think
in this shot things still look
reasonably under control but there is
fighting going on I mean at least he has
a determined look on his face rather
than one of sheer terror or panic he
doesn't yet look like they might be
getting overrun by wights or something
like that part of the reason why I find
this image so interesting is because of
how it might tie in with the next one
though in the next shot we see Jon
again we see him drawing his sword and
this doesn't appear to be related to any
of the other shots of him fighting that
we've seen so far here you can clearly
see trees in the background and that
would mean he's at the godswood as well
the initial response I had was this is
it the night King took the bait and this
is the beginning of their fight it could
be that but as of yet we haven't seen
any actual evidence that the night king
has arrived the grimmer idea that set in
is that this might be a really difficult
scene what if Theon has been killed and
is now white this could be Jon getting
ready to kill him it's just an idea
though based entirely on the fact that
they're in the same place and that it
would make for a heartbreaking moment
then we come back to John and Daenerys
where we saw them at the beginning of
the trailer and she says the dead are
already here directly to him this could
be related to Jon saying that the night
is coming as an answer to that and that
was my initial thought John wants to
wait to use the dragons to defend bran
when the night King arrives and Daenerys
wants to join the battle now because
there people are getting slaughtered in
the field in front of Winterfell those
seem like reasonable motivations for
both characters this shot is from a
different angle though so you can't see
what's going on in the distance at all
still I think this is the most likely
scenario that's happening they made a
plan in episode 2 we know what that is
Jon wants to stick to it because it's
Bran in the godswood and he knows how
important it is to defeat the night king
Daenerys is having trouble watching her
army be wiped out and wants to change
the plan and take action there is an
alternate idea which seems to be popular
out there that she's talking about the
dead inside the crypts this doesn't seem
likely to me for a couple of reasons
sure it's a popular idea that the knight
King will raise the dead in the
Winterfell crypts if he could raise the
dead from anywhere why not just raise
every dead person in every grave in
Westeros let them destroy all the living
people and just sit back and wait until
it's over
also if this was just a planning mistake
and that they weren't thinking about it
and they decided but all the innocents
in the crypt with generations of dead
bodies which of course they did what
could have happened at this point to
make Dany think about this right at this
moment so to me this seems like a
strategic conversation based on the
severity of the battle you guys can tell
me what you think in the comments
final shots of the trailer on the
battlefield we see sir Brienne with Sir
Jaime by her side we can see the sigil
of the Vale on the soldiers directly
behind her and we hear her shout hold
your ground this is pretty
straightforward based on what we learned
about her role in the battle on episode
2 what we've seen on the map all of that
it's chilling to see Jaime out front
with her and it looks like they're
getting ready for the first wave of the
army of the deads attack I guess that's
not a big surprise we know these two are
warriors that they're gonna go down
fighting if they go down but it's still
a little bit crazy to see what we're in
for
in the next episode the trailer ends
there and we are ready to go
so for what's hyped up to be the most
epic
see never film this trailer doesn't fill
in many blanks it does set the stage for
what we know is coming and it's feeling
pretty real at this point the big thing
that's missing here is the night king
himself and that has led to a lot of
speculation of course we didn't see him
lined up with the other white walkers at
the end of episode 2 and people have
been talking about that ever since
primarily around the idea that he won't
show up at Winterfell at all and that he
has another plan in mind I think to
really look at that idea I need to make
a separate video so my plan is to do
that next what we do see here is that
Jon and Daenerys start out away from the
action which follows the plan we watch
them arrive at in the last episode we
see that they're gonna have a hard
choice to make and that they may
disagree on what they need to do we see
that Jon will definitely be in the thick
of the action on the ground before too
long and that one of the Dragons will be
involved in some capacity since I want
to make another video to explore what
the night King might be doing and
whether or not he might show up before
the Battle of Winterfell is over I'm
gonna leave it here I know the popular
theory going around that I keep seeing
in my comments anyway is that he'll go
south while his army is attacking
Winterfell for me that doesn't make
sense for a couple of different reasons
but I want to take a closer look at that
conversation that's going on around that
before I get into it so that's it for
today I'm curious to hear what you guys
think about the trailer so let me know
in the comments did I miss anything what
do you think's going on with Jon and
Daenerys who will live and who will die
let me know what you think please like
the video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you want more
regular Game of Thrones videos
throughout the rest of the season 8
thanks for watching I will talk to you
soon